wir beginnen jetzt mit der einsatz
kommando übergabe des media quarter
horse eine einsatz mäßige
kommandoübergabe verlangt nicht viele
worte lassen sie nicht bekennen dass ich
mit leib und seele soldat des
österreichischen bundesheers bahn und
bin ich habe mein restliches leben immer
in vollen zügen genossen
ich konnte kreativ sein sich durch
gefordert aber auch helfen einen
wichtigsten dienst habe ich in tiroler
flut es lebe das militärkommando tirol
ich melde mich was meiner funktion als
militärkommandant ab
[Musik]
es erfolgt jetzt die vor allem
übergangen
[Musik]
man muss etwas leben damit man für etwas
brennt man muss in seiner heimat und mit
dem bundesheer verwurzelt sein um sich
selbst dafür hinzugeben
mein dank gilt aber auch allen
politischen entscheidungsträgern die
vertrauen in mich gesetzt haben und mich
unterstützt haben
abschließend möchte ich noch einmal
versichern dass ich mit all meinen
kräften und fähigkeiten diese ehrenvolle
anspruchsvolle herausfordernde und
wichtige kommandanten tätigkeit
wahrnehmen würde
lieber erwert du hast das
militärkommando tirol und die
sicherheits community in tirol und weit
darüber hinaus mitgeprägt für seine
umfangreichen verdienste um das
bundesland wurde das ehrenzeichen des
landes tirol und die ähren wirtschaft
der universität innsbruck verliehen
ich darf dir und deiner familie einen
wunderschönen weiteren lebensweg bei
bester gesundheit wünschen vielen
herzlichen dank
zu meiner großen freude wurde oberst
klein zum pionier offiziere ausgebildet
fünf jahre lang war oberst streit im
kabinett von 6 und s ministern tätig ein
würdiger und bestens geeigneter
nachfolger
ich wünsche dir viel erfolg viel energie
und alles erdenkliche soldatenglück ich
danke schön
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
lieber herr baird du warst immer ein
vorbild für viele offiziere als äußerst
einsatz villiger und jederzeit
verantwortungsbewusster
militärkommandant und ich möchte mich im
namen des dienstes aber auch persönlich
bei dir sehr herzlich für deinen einsatz
und deine leistung bedanken
ich möchte meinem nachfolger dir lieber
in offstein für soldaten glückwünschen
für diese verantwortungsvolle aufgabe
nun möchte er nun lieber herbert bei
dieser kommandoübergabe herzlich danken
für die persönliche unterstützung die
die du mir gegeben hast wohl auch der
eine tätigkeit als militärkommandant wo
ich den landeshauptmann wahl ist
einziger du bist ganz toller mensch er
ist einfach kanzler qualität und du bist
ein aber die verlässlichkeit ganz
besonders ausgeprägt ist ich danke dir
selbst rein dir meine herzlichen grüße
meine glückwünsche und wünsche hoffe auf
eine gute zusammenarbeit
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
und es lebe unser land gerollt
es ist mir ein ganz besonderes bedürfnis
dass ich mich als bundesministerin
hiermit auch offiziell für ein
engagement bedanken
dein einsatz der ist vielen anderen
soldatinnen und soldaten ein ganz
besonderes vorbild
ich wünsche dir nun vor allem eines
alles gute und gerade in diesen zeiten
viel gesundheit oberstein ich bin
überzeugt davon dass du diese ehrenvolle
wichtige vor allem auch fordernde
aufgabe großartig meistern wirst es lebe
das österreichische bundesheer es lebe
die republik österreich
[Musik]